what's up guys and welcome to Haris
hobbies the channel where we discussed
the latest tech news and delve into the
newest tech products today we're taking
at the 1180 which is coming out very
soon and how its performance is going to
be absolutely insane but before we begin
make sure to hit that subscribe button
if haven't already if you want to be
updated with the latest tech news
related to gaming and pcs so what
exactly happened and when is this new
GPU coming out even though Nvidia didn't
tell us anything about the new series of
GPUs at GDC gamer nexus was actually
able to get in contact with sk highness
who is the memory producer for nvidia
and produces they're like gddr5 memory
and what sk highest total gamer nexus
was that they are about to start mass
production of gdb are 6 memory in just
three months and why else would SK
Highness begin or mass production unless
an immediate need of it so this is where
the speculation or originates from also
this coincides with what Tom's Harvard
suggested just a few weeks ago about the
release of the new series of GPUs from
Nvidia that's why we were thinking that
this new series is going to come soon
so what about the performance how is it
going to perform well obviously you
didn't even tell us what I was going to
come out and so invaded it hasn't really
dropped any clues about its performance
and there really hasn't been any leaks
or rumors but what we can do is that we
can safely assume that it's performance
is going to match last generations gap
so for example last generation the 1060
was equal with the 980 more or less
answered this generation the 1160 should
be more or less equal with the 1080 also
last generation 2 980 s and sli was
about equal with the 1180 in some games
that two 980 s did better in some games
the 1080 did better
depending on how optimized the game was
for sli so this generation I think we
can safely assume that the 1180 will be
about the performance of 210 ATS in SLI
in some games the 1080s in a sly would
do better and in some games
11:8 he should do better also the 1180
would be the much superior choice to to
1080s
because obviously it would provide more
value because it wouldn't be like $1,600
and games wouldn't need to specifically
be optimized for it because it's only
one graphics cards so that's pretty much
what we're looking at for performance we
don't really know anything but we can
assume or safely predict that it's gonna
be the same generational gap as last
time and that's actually been a gonna be
absolutely awesome
imagine a mid tier card like the 1160
which can it cost around two hundred and
three hundred dollars yet it can't
perform the same as the 1080 and so this
is obviously gonna be a great new
introduction and getting offer much more
value and performance for the mid-level
user as well as the high end user so
when exactly are these new GPU is going
to come out well considering that SK
Highness has told us that they're going
to start production of gddr3 in July I
think we can safely assume that this new
series is going to be coming up at the
end of summer as an August or September
but it really likes to stagger the
releases so I think the 1170 and 1180
will probably come out at the end of
summer and the 1115 1160 will come out
at the end of the year and other
variants like the 1150 Ti and lemon atti
will come out sometime next year so
that's what the release schedule for a
media looks like so the performance
looks great and it's coming up pretty
soon but what about the price well in
the lower level cards the price should
actually be that bad let's say that 1060
was about $200 $200 I release the lemon
60 we're probably looking at about 250
to $300 pick us up the gtp our six
memory which is more expensive than
gddr5 memory if you assume that GPU
price is stabilized and mining craze is
over however the higher level cards are
actually going to be more expensive what
then what last generation came out for
like last generation that 1080 the MSRP
was 599 dollars but this generation
the 1180 could be looking at six hundred
nine nine dollars or even higher at
eight hundred two thousand dollars well
if you didn't know already just a one
month ago it was suggested that the
eleven eighty was actually going to cost
fifteen hundred dollars because the
reasoning was that Nvidia wouldn't want
to release a new generation card that
was cheaper than current generation
garden for example it was argued that
Nvidia wouldn't want to place the eleven
eighty in a situation where the 1080
which provides less performance than the
lemon ad to be more expensive and since
the ten eighty TI's and ten 80s are
really expensive right now as in like
thousand to twelve hundred dollars it
was expected that the eleven eighty was
going to be even more well first of all
these new GPUs are going to implement
gdb our six memory and GDD our six
memory is expected to be twenty percent
more expensive than what gddr5 memory
was at launch
however GD our six memory does provide
twice the performance of gddr5 and so I
do think it's worth the extra price but
even then it is increasing the price on
top of this I do think there is some
truth to anybody and not wanting their
current generation cards to be more
expensive than new generation cards by
the time that these new cards come out I
do think that the 1080 and 1080 ice will
heavily drop from what their current
prices at over thousand dollars into
like maybe a six hundred to eight
hundred dollar range or even MSRP if RAM
situation works out but even then GPU
prices will continue it to be at least a
little inflated and so I do think that
the 1180 is going to be more expensive
than $600 at release and the thing is
the lemma is provide you so much
performance that even if NVIDIA bumps up
the price by a hundred or two hundred
dollars their value per dollar is
actually better so for the people who
care about value per dollar they're
still gonna go out and buy it but for
the people who are on budget oriented
and really care about what the final
price of the graphics card is there it's
gonna really affect them and
even if they're looking at lower level
card it's still gonna be more expensive
than last generation and the worst thing
is is that Nvidia really has no
competition from AMD and so people don't
have an alternative so the people who
want that much performance and it is
reasonable price it's not that it's not
a reasonable price
it's just that converts last generation
it's more expensive for the flagship so
the people who want that performance
they would see it as a reasonably priced
and would buy it and as a result in
video is still get a lot of sales and
make more money when compared to if they
price is cheaper so as a result I think
invidious new series is going to be more
expensive across the board due to no
competition and play the GPU prices and
GDD are six memory but despite that the
performance is still really great and
the value per dollar is actually much
better so I recommend that you guys
still consider buying this new GPUs even
if it's a bit out of your range maybe by
waiting a little bit longer and or
waiting for the deals coming out on
Black Friday or Christmas so what
exactly happened well SK Hynix told
gamers Nexus that there is going to be a
mass production of GD r6 that's starting
very soon and so we're assuming that
this is what's going to be going to be
used in Nvidia and as a result we assume
that the new generation of GPUs are
going to be coming out very soon and
using last generational gaps this
generation should have a really great
performance and since its using gt-r six
memory and as a result the new series
should perform much better when compared
to last generation unfortunately however
the new generation is going to be more
expensive to a variety of reasons and so
it may be out of reach for some of you
guys but A+ with the new generation is
that once the new generation comes out
current generation 10 series cards are
actually gonna drop more in price and so
you guys may be able to afford a higher
level card there so let's say you were
on it to buy a 1060 then after this
release you guys may even be able to
afford the 1070 do the deep price drop
so make sure to consider that too when
you guys are thinking about buying GPU
now or to wait for it but that's pretty
much all I have for you guys
this time make sure to post in the
comments down below what you guys think
about this for example do you think that
it's about time for a Nvidia to come out
with this new generation and weight
thing about AMD or do you think they're
gonna kill it with navi or do you really
think they don't know what they're doing
and they're just stuck make sure to post
down comments below what you think
because I do read all my comments and
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
to drop a like on it and subscribe if
you would like to see more videos just
like this one but until next time
[Music]